the CDC tells CBS News it will likely
issue an alert to doctors this week
about the new illness that's affecting
children senior medical correspondent
dr. tara nurullah joins us more to
discuss this Tara this is so disturbing
because in the beginning we were told
kovat 19 doesn't really affect kids that
clearly does not appear to be the case
now and as a mother of two gorgeous
young daughters you know nothing gets to
parents more than anything or anyone
affecting their children so what two
doctors know about these latest symptoms
you're absolutely right Gail I mean this
is really what every parent fears and
one of the doctors we spoke to yesterday
said it really well she said no one saw
this coming and that seems to be the
feeling about this virus that we're
constantly playing catch-up with what's
happening what we know so far is that it
does seem to this syndrome seems to be
occurring in areas where we're
experiencing high rates of kovin
infection so while there's no definitive
link yet to kovat most experts believe
that this is a post viral immune
abnormal response in genetically
susceptible kids we know that this is
happening in kids who are previously
healthy it seems to occur within days
two weeks after potentially getting
infected and it shares these overlap
features with toxic shock syndrome and
Kawasaki disease where it differs from
Kawasaki is that it's happening in older
kids Kawasaki is usually under the age
of five we're also seeing a lot of these
gastrointestinal involvement and also a
profound involvement of the
cardiovascular system where kids are
really developing heart failure and
heart muscle dysfunction and that can
lead to the shock and low blood pressure
that these kids are developing is there
an effective treatment well that's one
good thing one little silver lining is
that it does seem that the treatment for
Kawasaki appears to be effective for
these kids and that treatment is IVIG
sometimes steroids immune modulators and
blood pressure supporting medication so
overall if children developed this
syndrome the prognosis seems to be
pretty good so what exactly should
parents be looking for and are some kids
more at risk than others boys versus
girls
versus boys well one really important
thing that every expert stressed and I
want everyone in the public to hear this
is that this is extremely rare so even
though we're all afraid this is a rare
syndrome but it is important to be aware
so by awareness parents should be
looking for fever that last several days
abdominal symptoms like pain nausea
vomiting also changes in the skin or the
color of the hands and a rash and
bloodshot eyes when things are getting
worse you might actually see a bluish
tint to the lips the kids might complain
of chest pain or heart racing or
shortness of breath as far as who seems
to be more susceptible it does seem that
boys have this a little bit more
frequently than girls which we also see
with Kawasaki and children of
african-american descent as well all
right we will all be looking thank you
very much Tara